auf und davon mit mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Musik]
pläne cornelia breit schmiede und schon
maries mutter wurden in marokko eine
kleine feriensiedlung bauen
neues leben neues glück die familie
händler übernimmt den schwedisch
lappland eine hotel und campinganlage
und auf und davon in ein neues abenteuer
mit kamelen zieht die familie blum durch
das australische outback
[Musik]
die abenteurer familie blum
genießt die vorteile der zivilisation
solange sie noch krach bald ist schluss
mit saft pressen
in der wildnis werden andere geräte
wichtig sein sabrina braucht deshalb
eine lizenz zu schießen
[Applaus]
das ich mir leisten machen
die welt wie die population von der
armenischen erstrahle und wenn denn da
sowohl die bilder
gekommen ist
das sehr verachtet und in dieser krise
die musiker mehr kaputt und im
schlimmsten fall den
dank ihres australischen pass kann
sabrina den waffenschein einfach
erwerben als markus es wird also hierzu
mit dem gewehr die familie zu beschützen
in der letzten folge von offen davon
kaum in schweden angekommen musste die
feuerwehr her
max henzlers katze wurde gerettet
ehefrau jasmin hat zum ersten mal in
österreich
große pläne in marokko
ohne eigentlich ist voll da weg und
autos mit riemen pohl allerdings in
sachen baubewilligungen ging gar nichts
[Musik]
in australien erfuhren die blumes wie
schwierig es ist wilde kamele zu
trainieren
[Musik]
und die kinder hatten ihren ersten
schultag
[Musik]
und wohin ist die gute seele der familie
henzler
noch schnarcht er zufrieden doch sein
großer einsatz wird noch kommen
überall türmt sich die arbeit bei den
frisch ausgewanderten
wirklich und
sich anfühlen
[Musik]
die familie henzler hat im norden von
schweden eine große ferien und
campinganlage gekauft
[Musik]
wenn du da bist dann nehme ich einen
kaffee
angelika ist eine von zwei angestellten
die max übernommen hat zurzeit sie nur
wenige gäste da
max henzler will den camping betrieb
aufrechterhalten obwohl viele
innovationen und aufräumarbeiten
anstehen
grad
getrocknet
punkt sind jetzt nicht das ärgert mich
maßlos acht
denke der berufungs pokal beim kauf der
anlage gab es viel gerümpel gratis
obendrauf
oh ja
shoppen ausmisten und entsorgen mehr
noch max beginnt gleich zu renovieren
denn schließlich sind da noch viele
ideen die er zu verwirklichen hofft
koch lebt er hat helfer aus dem dorf
organisiert
die decke des restaurants braucht
dringend einen neuen anstrich
für die recht große an dreck zieht
jahrhundert bewegt hat
im oberen bereich und das rote meer
könnten meint mit potsdam zum zum
heutigen buren also nahezu machtlos
war
eine heidenarbeit
für macs nicht nur die basis für eine
neue existenz sondern auch grundlage für
seine innere balance nach einem burnout
das ist einerseits natürlich
vision und unsere idee war mir umsätze
gemeinsam strom hängt den wunschtraum
und auch in der umsetzung gleichzeitig
ist für mich die therapie ich meine
netzhaut kipping es anders aus
für millionen auf machen
[Musik]
frühmorgens im outback die blumes fahren
zu ihren freunden zur familie geboren
ist dort soll sabrina schießen lernen
früh unterwegs sind auch kängurus
[Musik]
sabrina hatte ein känguru angefahren
das ist
bewegt
aber sie hat nicht ehrlich
disney comics mieters lebt nun ja
[Musik]
von
mit typisch und andere sportler gab es
passiert etwas mit mir passiert inhalte
eine rolle dass man direkt vor
seinem 100
[Musik]
war
vielleicht mag der kauf einer ziegen
ledernen tasche die stimmung der
aargauer auswanderer etwas aufhellen
die
schönheit ihr spur
von ihrer breit schmiede und strom
arizona sind angespannt
mit einem großen traum kamen sie nach
marokko dem traum einer eigenen
feriensiedlung doch kaum angekommen in
der fremde läuft gar nichts mehr ihr
gesuch für eine baubewilligung verstaubt
irgendwo auf einem stapel in der
marokkanischen bürokratie
cornelia und jo marie fühlen sich
machtlos
[Musik]
die zeit drängt die frist um ihr
grundstück erwerben zu können läuft die
in nächster
jetzt hoffen die beiden auf eine audienz
beim gouverneur von sr ihrer ihre
architektin sollte sich um den termin
kümmern doch sie ist wie vom erdboden
verschluckt
[Musik]
die araber treffen auf kollege didier
und mit ihm kommt auch der lang ersehnte
anruf der architektin
was ich verstanden habe ist das see- und
sagt wenn wir zum glück
es kann schnell gehen sagt ich hoffe es
ist nicht relevant genug ja ja die hat
was getan
könnte klappen
[Musik]
in schweden wird die arbeit nicht
weniger auf familienvater max lastet
phoenix ist einer der sich einiges
abverlangt trotz der herkules aufgabe
will er ein präsent der vater sein und
so viel zeit wie möglich mit seinen
buben verbringen
das ist wahr
eine gruppe
dass du mich
hund brian möchte in der nähe seines
herrchens sein
kannst du das checkout übernehmen
vieles ist neu für max und selbst
alltägliche kleinigkeiten muss er zuerst
lernen
so das musst du mir jetzt zeigen
und sie ist auch nicht
ja
kein tierarzt in der nähe die familie
blum bringt das verletzte känguru baby
direkt zur farm der familie geboren ist
tochter holly hat soeben einen krebs
gefangen
das ist gestorben
[Musik]
unter fahrern gelten kängurus gemeinhin
als plage doch dieses känguru baby
findet seine ewige ruhe unter einem
gummiband
und ewig werden wohl auch die
blumenmädchen dieses kleine geschöpf in
erinnerung behalten
[Musik]
trotz des traurigen zwischenfalls
sabrina muss lernen zu schießen
norton bornes zeigt ihr wie eine
winchester die australische jagdwaffe
schlechthin funktioniert
schließlich aus freien stand nein du
kannst das gewehr auf dem wagen auf
stützen
[Musik]
wo sind die pizzen ich sehe nichts
ok ich sehe die füchse
jetzt ist sie wieder weg
es ist ein
faktum ist dass henry thom und jude law
das lg
[Musik]
auf den wüsten trip wird sabrina eine
schrotflinte mitnehmen denn nur mit
einer stadt kann könnte sie im notfall
einen wildgewordenen kamel bullen zur
strecke bringen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ein kleiner funken hoffnung hat sich in
die herzen der marokko auswanderer
geschlichen
hoffnung dass ihre architektin gute
neuigkeiten hat
wo haben sie diese visitenkarten machen
lassen jo marie ist zu nettigkeiten
nicht aufgelegt
also wo stehen wir nun
entschuldigen sie bete dass ich sie
gestern nicht angerufen habe die mutter
meiner freundin ist gestorben ich war
bei ihr und habe sie unterstützt
ich habe die anfrage um eine audienz
beim gouverneur vorbereitet
[Musik]
wir werden diese anfrage ist gleich beim
kabinettchef abgeben
[Musik]
ihr könnt jetzt der täter gab das ab und
wartete bis er den ruf reagiert für mich
ist
solide gewachsen
ok
[Musik]
wirkliche zuversicht mag sich nicht
einstellen auch die erklärung der
architektin weshalb sie sich nicht
gemeldet hatte überzeugt die auswanderer
nicht
[Musik]
zum glück ist pragmatisch
ich kenne die abläufe ich weiß ist dass
jetzt weg sieht der wagen muss gas
brieflich schrieb
möchte das ganze
falls
der kunde sofort und die kunden dort tat
oder
[Musik]
persönlich geben die beiden das audienz
gesucht im gouverneurssitz ab
[Musik]
ich bin max der neue besitzer der anlage
um ein schwedisch ist nicht so gut
[Musik]
der sensible geheim scheint zu spüren
dass max nervlich belastet ist
es ist offen
wollen sie reservieren
[Musik]
gestern davon darauf betrieb
neu legen im gastgewerbe bauleiter und
familienvater max ist gefordert und
nicht zuletzt muss er als besitzer einer
großen hotel und campinganlage auch
scheinbaren kleinkram fest im griff am
nächsten dienstag kommt einer von der
versicherungsgesellschaft
wir brauchen überall feuerlöscher
[Musik]
haben wir einen beim eingang
ja aber das ist auch der einzige den wir
haben wir brauchen aber in jedem
häuschen einem feuerlöscher
und alte erarbeiten und ansprüche an
sich selbst wird max immer dünnhäutiger
naja
konnte schon
[Musik]
macho
die blues stehen vor einem
entscheidenden schritt
noch vor wenigen monaten lebten diese
kamele wild im outback seither versuchen
sabrina und markus in täglichem training
die tiere zu zählen
[Musik]
premiere für die kamele damen loona und
molly
kamelhof bis sie zur pole ließ ein
erfahrener kamel flüsterer hilft mit die
kamele zum ersten mal vor einen wagen zu
spannen
[Musik]
die bereits ausgebildete milli soll die
zugtiere anführen und die richtung
vorgeben
[Musik]
aber irgendwie bringen und zwar gerade
durch
die tiere auf kurs halten ist das ein
doch zuerst müssen sie sich überhaupt
wieder bewegen
[Musik]
und dann geht es plötzlich ganz schnell
auch in marokko ging es für einmal
schnell
eigentlich hatten cornelia und
jean-marie glück sie konnten mit dem
staatschef des gouverneurs reden doch
das gespräch war eine enttäuschung
hier liegt um 200.000 dosen sonnenwagen
stativ organisatorische gründe
hat jetzt zeit weil die druck machen
dass die ethos sie was es ist nicht nur
äußerst erste modell ich vor 30 landes
in biloxi das gleiche problem hat aber
es sind jetzt auf unsere oktober normale
und also die nächste woche nächste
gelegenheit das thema krieg vergessen
hätte ich mir schon vorstellen dass er
beläuft aber er sagt jetzt konkretes
datum natürlichen gehe aber jetzt ist
versprochen dass sie jetzt dass das so
schnell wenn etwas gut im momentan nicht
so einen kopf und und bühne zu stehen
wir haben es in den
[Musik]
afrikanischen maschinerie funktioniert
anders das haben wir schon grüßt
ok
[Musik]
sehr schön 7 sich so
also vermutlich
nicht
wollte
[Musik]
ich nehme meine taschen mit hackbällchen
und gemüse
und ich nehme die mit pulli und zitrone
und auch gemüse und
was man es machen das ist als taxi oder
und da in marokko ist das selbst
besuchen wir das schon zu spüren
wir forschen die viele hus dass man noch
so eben so finden wir alle jeden
letztendlich den ganzen fall einer tat
richtig gut ist und
[Musik]
das abenteuer bei minustemperaturen
kümmern sich die henzlers ganz besonders
um die katze
vor allem max fühlt sich verantwortlich
für eine
katze und kind plötzlich ist alles zu
viel
[Musik]
ich habe nur die
bitte
ja da kann uns ja jemand blendet
den wechsel zu machen doch
was ist los
was ich
ja das
mache ich wenn ich
nur schon heute so streng und
damit der nachwuchs
das
erklärte der klar machen ausflüge
unternehmen gezählt aber jeden tag
darum sind wir jetzt mobilisieren dass
man die lücken die ich stelle
mit dem stress und
mit dieser tombola also
spricht
[Musik]
du musst nur sowas eingriff ist gut
alles gut muss nicht weiter
[Musik]
aber
in australien geht nichts mehr die
zugtiere haben das leid kamele weit
hinter sich gelassen und streiten
jetzt hilft nur der trick mit dem wasser
doch auch ihre tricks
[Musik]
ist markus mit dem leid kamel
das werden
vor allem werden
sowohl
red
[Musik]
trotz des nicht gerade ermutigenden
besuch 7 gouverneurssitz blicken die
aargauer auswanderer weiter nach vorne
im norden von avira besichtigen sie die
baustelle eines kleinen hotels
zwar gehört das hotel nicht ihnen aber
der rohbau zeigt bauern in marokko ist
eine langwierige angelegenheit
ich stimme
machen gerade realismus ich sage aber
sie stehen also gut
dass
die klinik zehn metern
45 3 aber da wird der hauptgewinn er war
größer
die baustelle dient den beiden als
inspiration für ihr eigenes kleines
projekt einer feriensiedlung
[Musik]
zurück in der stadt so jean marie einen
papier auf
einfach keine stufen steigen
jean marie ist immer noch überzeugt dass
es ihnen gelingen wird die
baubewilligung zu bekommen und das
grundstück zu kaufen
ich habe noch viele haare wie ein schaf
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
also ich bin optimist
digital und
die entscheidung muss ein bisschen mehr
auf dieser seite also
und ich bin noch nie so richtig über den
tisch gezogen wurde
felix frage bin ich sehr glücklich
portion
vorsicht die medien haben das ist so
das haben sie gut gemacht
[Musik]
hallo hallo
so hart
bis 10
das sei
sowieso herz wildsau
sich am 100
macht sei stolz
hinzu
[Musik]
in schweden hat sich max wieder beruhigt
markelow hatte
seit 14 jahren sind die händlers ein
paar
jasmin kämpft die gefühlswelt ihres
mannes
manches andere tracht
er will zwar eine schöne und das gute
[Musik]
max besinnt sich wieder auf das
wesentliche
loslassen und die familie genießen
[Musik]
zum glück machen familien
doch max wäre nicht max würde er einfach
mit einem streichholz das feuer
entfachte
[Musik]
statt der ohnehin
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
aus und vorbei dem roper auswanderer
kapitulieren
die beiden haben eine neue idee und
stehen somit vor neuen hindernissen er
nur eine arabische tastatur
[Musik]
unerwartete probleme in australien
die besitzer wurden ihre kamele nicht
hergeben
wird eine aussprachen ihr abenteuer
retten können
die henzlers feiern mit sommerfest
nur etwas ging dabei komplett vergessen
sie bedienen
wenn ich nicht die gehwege mit alkohol
kommen
muss
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge